hola
qué bueno que están aquí muchísimas
gracias a todos por acompañarnos vamos a
ver qué tan despiertos está en el día de
hoy les parece
no los escucho
perfecto vamos a empezar vamos a ver
señor qué es esto
un polvo para hacer pasteles muy bien
quien me puede ayudar en decirme qué es
lo que ven en la pantalla paloma
una bola de estambre y para qué sirve
tejer cosas muy bien esto que es me
puedes ayudar por favor
no sabes que es alguien que sepa para
qué es
un pañuelo y para qué sirve
es una tela y para qué sirve
una manta muy bien a ver la que sigue a
ver qué tal esto que es y para qué
sirven
para los dientes para pintar muy bien
esto qué es
no
esto es un papel y para qué sirve
puede servir para envolver
y todos juntos
alguien que me pueda ayudar para decirme
para qué sirve una lata de royal
una tela
un estambre unos palillos y un
papel
para ser un tambor muy bien
para hacer un tambor
si hubieran imaginado si esta misma
pregunta se la hubieran hecho cuando
ustedes tenían 67 años que hubieran
contestado
un niño no sabe
a qué se va a dedicar un niño ni
siquiera sabe si el próximo fin de
semana
jugar va a salir de viaje es más
ni siquiera sabe que me estudiarse iba a
ser ingeniero arquitecto abogado
psicólogo médico ni siquiera sabe si se
va a casar
pero un niño se atreve un niño está
dispuesto a caerse una y mil veces más
hasta lograrlo como por ejemplo una
bicicleta unión se sube la bicicleta
logra seguir su camino de frente incluso
sin llantas
les va a pedir un favor
piensen en aquello que les preocupa en
este momento
piensen en aquello que les está causando
ruido o que les está haciendo cosquillas
en la panza
ahora cierren sus ojos
vayan a una habitación y abran la puerta
ahí se encuentran
yo le hace de 8 años
para algunos hace 10 20 30 50 años
cuéntele por favor sus problemas
cuéntale eso que les incomoda que les
hace ruido
que creen que les diría a ese niño que
creen que les diría suyo de s
de esa versión
abran sus ojos y díganme por favor
en qué momento dejamos de creer de
sentir de soñar
y no hablo
de un tema de inmadurez
hablo de un niño que tenemos dentro los
niños confían en su creatividad
en su mente
en disfrutar cada uno de los momentos
un niño
único que desea en ese momento
y yo les quiero pedir un favor todas
esas o toda esa creatividad esa ilusión
esas ganas de vivir no las perdamos como
las perdemos conforme va pasando el
tiempo conforme vamos ilusionados de
querer estar
grande que tiene un niño
es el tesoro más grande que tiene un
niño y ahí me acuerdo la primera navidad
de emilio mi hijo que por cierto tiene
nueve años y estoy casado con diana
desde hace doce es importante decirlo
nos se cuentan los años
esa primera navidad
yo no sé si quería sacar mis
frustraciones o si quería sacar
carencias
idiana mi esposa y yo entramos en un
debate de cuántos regalos teníamos que
darle emilio por supuesto que ella en su
afán de educar y hacerlo pues que no se
volviera materialista entre otras tantas
cosas me dijo vamos a darle un solo
regalo evidentemente yo decía nombre 45
los que sean
ya sabrán quién ganó en ese momento por
supuesto que yo
y le dimos muchos regalos y me acuerdo
que había uno que según yo era el que
iba a transformar esa navidad con la
misma alegría que el quite el papel abrí
la caja
saqué el juguete que dio juguete juguete
y en más o menos menos de un minuto dejó
el juguete de un lado y se metió a la
caja
y toda la noche pasó jugando en esa caja
tan simple como una caja simplicidad sin
duda así de simple
pues nos metemos tanta maraña
queremos ese regalo te en vez de algo
tan simple
déjenme platicarles otra cosa hace tres
semanas solo hace tres semanas yo no sé
si ustedes saben pero los organizadores
han cuidado meticulosamente cada detalle
tanto que nos pidieron hace tres semanas
que les platicamos que hiciéramos una
breve presentación de lo que era nuestra
plática
déjenme decirle que se la acabaron por
completo perdió el rumbo de lo que yo
tenía que decirles pero saben qué
les estoy muy agradecido porque estaba
perdiendo el propósito de estar hoy aquí
estaba perdiendo ese rumbo me sentía
como en un restaurante de estos el you
can it con un plato desbordado de comida
cuando lo único que tenía cuando lo
único que tenía era 20 minutos
en qué momento me pasó eso
de momento me dejé llevar
porque estamos y porque nos complicamos
ante las cosas
porque nos vestimos como nos vestimos
porque actuamos como actuamos o le
hacemos querer ver a los demás lo que
ellos quieren ver y no lo que nosotros
queremos ver
déjenme decirles
el actor principal de sus vidas es cada
uno de ustedes
cada uno de ustedes tiene un motivo en
su vida pero a la vez cada uno de
ustedes es un actor secundario
el simple hecho de sacar su mejor
versión
la de cada uno de ustedes
ya estamos influyendo en esas vidas
la plenitud se alcanza cuando se deja de
buscar
cuando dejamos de pretender ser
para solo ser
no nos compliquemos y dejemos de
buscarle tres pies al gato así de simple
así de fácil
vivamos porque nadie absolutamente nadie
es mejor que uno mismo que uno mismo
déjenme platicarles otra historia
hace tres años
la semana más complicada de mi trabajo
tenía
cena de gala
un evento que saque la mejor y la peor
versión de mí un evento que estaba
cuidando cada uno de los pequeños
detalles según yo
un evento donde lleve al límite a mis
colaboradores incluso a desgastarlos me
desgasté yo también
por cuidar esos pequeños detalles
sin darme cuenta
que estaba yo descuidando salió el
evento salió bien
algunos detalles que no salieron pero la
gente que estaba ni siquiera lo vivió ni
siquiera lo sintió este fin de semana
fuimos a visitar a mis papás que por
cierto
yo no sé que tienen los papás y ustedes
me pueden ayudar pero no sé que tienen
los papás que nada más de casas y
desmantela en tu cuarto
yo no sé que tienen pero lo vuelven un
cuarto de televisión un cuarto de estar
el despacho el de cositas el de ballena
sabe bueno pues fue el caso de mis papás
y lo que hicieron es que lo convirtieron
en el cuarto de visitas
ahí estaba la cama de mi hermano y la
mía dos individuales y esa noche esa
noche me tocó dormir con sofía mi hija
me acordó que las 3 de la mañana me
desperté con una sensación de que el
cuerpo me quemaba
tomé un poco de agua y en ese momento
necesitaba ir al baño me paré por
supuesto sin prender la luz
caminando lento en la oscuridad
ya nada de llegar al baño
si hay un ruido que despertó a mi esposa
se paró imagínense una doctora gritando
desesperadamente en el piso que escena
cuando por fin logré despertar y verme
tumbado en el piso
porque mi cerebro se conectó con mi
cuerpo y fue donde mi cuerpo me estaba
pidiendo a gritos descansa no te
compliques deja de ver o de quererle dar
a los demás y en ese momento es donde
tendí esa simpleza de las cosas donde
volví a conectarlas es donde entendí que
tenía que estar y no complicando me en
querer darle a alguien más lo que tenía
ahí allí de frente
qué impresión y déjenme decirles algo
simpleza es igual a plenitud tan simple
como con basura reciclada hacer un robot
que incluso tiene a su juguete
tan simple como una hoja de papel
se vuelve un mundo pirata
o se vuelve a tu familia
tan simple
hoja de papel
igual la plenitud
y ustedes creen que esto fue fácil la
respuesta es no
hace unos años en un viaje relámpago y
déjenme preguntarles qué harían ustedes
si trabajan toda una tarde toda una
noche se desvelan durante cuatro días
y se suben a un avión de regreso a su
casa que es lo primero que ustedes
harían al subirse a ese avión
dormir oye y qué sucede si al lado de ti
va una señora estás típica señora ese
estereotipo perfecto el señora que te
quieren sacar la sopa de todo lo que has
hecho incluso que fuiste a dónde vas y
con quién estuviste qué haría si
estuviera sentado al lado de esta señora
le dices ya cayese señor o te duermes
pues déjenme decirles
qué fue lo que pasó ese viaje relámpago
a ibiza un miércoles en la noche de
regreso ese domingo en la madrugada lo
que yo quería era dormirme
y le pedí a gritos a dios que me tocará
al lado nadie porque quería dormir y
tuve el gusto y privilegio de tener
sentada sesión ahora hablamos de ella me
estuvo preguntando
sacando de la sopa y caí
y cuando me pregunta cuántos hijos tiene
si le digo uno en ese entonces
y dice que tan grande está en ese
momento instintivamente bajé mis manos y
le dije
en ese momento me di cuenta
que estaba en un lugar de trabajo donde
pretendía darle lo mejor a mi hijo
pero no estaba para verlo sólo lo veía
dormido
incluso a mi esposa siempre me esperaba
todas las noches somnoliento esperándome
y yo
y como les digo por supuesto que no fue
fácil darte cuenta pero le estoy muy
agradecido a esa señora que estaba
sentada al lado de mí porque sin saberlo
ella por el simple hecho de ser
cambio
y déjenme decirles
que yo iba en ese camino andando en
bicicleta
de frente
sin dentistas
y me caí
jóvenes
la próxima vez que se vean en un espejo
pregúntense
que se vean que es lo que quieren de su
vida
dónde están
escriban un libro que no han escrito
vivan una aventura que no han vivido
llámenle a una persona a la cual no le
han hablado en mucho tiempo vence cuenta
que es igualmente importante lo que
están haciendo en ese momento
ten se cuenta que es válido volver a
empezar de cero
dese en cuenta la próxima vez que se
vean que nunca absolutamente nunca
es tarde para volver a ser un niño
muchísimas gracias que estén muy bien